max principle as in mach number as in
the speed of sound well let's start off
back up a little bit i want to talk
about centripetal force and centrifugal
force because they're kind of sources of
much confusion and amusement people
commonly talk about centrifugal force
and then you learn a little bit of
physics and you get told actually
there's no such thing as centrifugal
force it's just a thing called
centripetal force and then if you go a
little bit further down the line maybe
you think well maybe there's both so we
should talk about them both actually so
bit of latin
fugo fugare means to flee so you're
fleeing the center of centrifugal forces
fleeing the center centripetal force
petto is i seek so it's actually seeking
the center
so one is fleeing the others seeking and
so one's going away from the center the
other is coming towards the center let's
start with a simple
thought experiment what i want is i want
a cylindrical room
with you standing in it and let's put
you on a pair of roller skates just to
make life simple and then i'm going to
start the room rotating around the
central axis
so what's going to happen well what's
going to happen is that as the room
rotates you're going to start moving
around as well but remember unless a
force is being applied to you your
natural tendency is you'll carry on in a
straight line
so if you're on roller skates then
there's probably not much by way of
friction which means you'll just slide
on the floor so as the thing starts to
rotate around you'll start traveling as
a thing rotates but you'll travel on in
a straight line so you'll head off in
this direction keep going in a straight
line
and then you're going to hit the wall
and that's the interesting thing that
actually at the point where you hit the
wall suddenly you're kind of pressed
against the wall as the thing rotates
and as it rotates faster and faster
you'll be pressed to the wall harder and
harder and that's why people think about
centrifugal forces because actually
you're being pressed to the wall so from
your perception in this rotating room
there is a centrifugal force right
you're being pushed outwards and you'll
be pressed against the wall and clearly
there's a centrifugal force whereas
somebody who's just watching the room
from above as we are here will say
actually no there isn't a centrifugal
force at all what's going on is that you
wanted to travel on in a straight line
but then this wall stopped you and
there's actually a centripetal force
it's pushed the wall is pushing you
towards the middle all the time and so
actually the force there is you know is
pushing you inwards there's a
centripetal force which is keeping you
going around in a circle as you're
pressed against the wall sounds like
centropedal was right then
it is kind of because that's the kind of
the bigger picture of you when you're
outside the rotating reference frame and
whereas you know if you're in the
rotating reference frame then
centrifugal force is what's going on but
in some sense what's more fundamental is
the rest of the universe that actually
is looking down on this thing seeing it
rotate we do learn that for every force
there's like an equal and opposite
though so doesn't it make sense that
both are happening at the same time at
that point indeed by the time you're
pressed to the wall you're neither being
accelerated away from the wall or
towards it so there's kind of a balance
of forces there thus the you can think
of the centrifugal forces pushing you
out with the central fetal forces
pushing inwards it all comes to the same
thing as you said in some sense that
centropetal force is kind of more
fundamental in the centrifugal case
you're kind of being fooled you think
you're in a non-rotating room right and
actually you're suddenly flung to the
wall and that's why you interpret as a
centrifugal force and therefore you're
being fooled because although the things
in the room around you aren't don't
appear to be rotating because they're
all rotating at the same speed you are
somebody looking down on this from above
so you can say actually you know the
whole thing's rotating and therefore the
centripetal force is fundamentally
what's going on but that's where we get
to mass principle
because the question you could ask is
how do you know you're rotating
how do you know it's just not the rest
of the universe rotating the other way
all the time when we were doing
relativity things we would always say
well you can't tell whether it's you
moving forwards and something else
stationary or you stationary and
something else moving backwards right
there was this kind of relativity there
so the obvious question is why isn't
there a relativity here why isn't it
equivalent to saying either the the room
is rotating and the rest of the universe
is stationary or the room stationary and
the rest of the universe is rotating the
other way because they both look the
same to an outside observer they you
know they're both ones things rotating
relative to the other i could do i can
answer that though okay if you created
that scenario for me there the person on
the roller skate wouldn't move
with the rest of the but but how does
the universe know right you're right
you're absolutely right but it means in
some sense rotation is absolute right
that actually you can tell the
difference between whether the room's
rotating and the rest of the universe is
stationary or whether the room
stationary and the rest of the universe
is rotating by the fact whether or not
on your roller skates you get pushed to
the outside and that's what mass
principle says is that actually the
physics of the small scale depends on
the large scale right that actually the
entire universe is somehow influencing
this room so that it that you actually
know that it's the room road that's
rotating and the rest of the universe is
stationary rather than the rest of the
universe that's rotating in the room
stationary somehow the two are talking
to each other they're talking to each
other and one's saying i'm the big guy
here and you're the little guy so you
you're the thing spinning not me exactly
although you know in principle you could
make the entire universe rotate if you
wanted to it'd be a lot of effort but
actually you know you could do it but
somehow
they know which is the thing that's
really rotating which is the thing that
isn't and that means somehow the physics
of the large scale is affecting what's
going on on the small scale the reason
why you know you're rotating is only by
reference to the entire universe around
you and another statement of mass
principle which is kind of the same
thing is that if you actually made the
entire universe rotate including this
room
you wouldn't be able to tell because
then there's nothing for it to be
rotating relative to coming back to just
the room in the universe yes the simple
version yeah has has anyone got any idea
how this
through what medium this information is
communicated between the room and the
universe not in detail i mean this is
why it's a principle rather than a law
is that actually it's just something
which we know has to be happening
because we can tell when we're in a
rotating room and when we're not but
what the mechanism is is not entirely
clear at least in detail this very much
influenced einstein when he was moving
on from special relativity to general
relativity because clearly he was very
kind of thinking about reference frames
because he'd done all that with special
relativity then you come to this general
relativity case where he knew perfectly
well that actually if you're in a
rotating room you know you were in a
rotating room because you get flung to
the walls and that was what made him
think that actually whatever is going on
in general relativity has to somehow
have mass principle imprinted in it and
indeed the laws of general relativity
say that what kind of affects the motion
on the small scale depends on the
distribution of mass all over the
universe because actually the curvature
of space the way that the space is
distorted on small scales depends on the
the distribution of mass throughout the
universe so actually in some sense sort
of has mass principle built into it
because the what's going on on the very
small scale in terms of particles being
accelerated around by gravity depends on
how space has been distorted which in
turn depends on the distribution of mass
throughout the universe so i think he
was very much inspired by mass principle
to think about the things which then led
to general relativity
i find this deeply disturbing that the
universe is talking to itself like this
and we have no idea how
it is no somehow that information on the
big picture of the universe is somehow
being communicated to the small scale so
einstein got very excited he was able to
show in within general relativity that
this is a strange effect that if you
have like a pendulum just swinging here
and you put a sphere around it and make
the sphere rotate
that actually makes the pendulum start
to process around
and so because actually effectively the
rotating mass is kind of dragging space
with it with affects what's going on so
he was quite excited that actually he
could show mathematically that actually
if the universe really is rotating
around an object it actually does have
an influence on the object
um so again there is this tie between
you know what's going on in the rascal
what's going on on the small scale but
beyond those kind of very specific cases
i don't think anyone's tackling the big
picture question of why max principle is
true in general
thanks for watching this video if you'd
like to help 60 symbols that little bit
more you can actually contribute on
patreon
just like the people whose name you're
seeing on the screen at the moment have
our thanks to them and our thanks to you
if you decide to participate there are
details here on the screen and in the
video description but as always the best
contribution you can make to 60 symbols
is to keep watching our videos to
subscribe to the channel and if you see
one you like maybe share it on social
media or tell your friends about it
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video